[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace conosur en esta
emisión desde buenos aires argentina
nuestro tema de hoy los 40 años de la
guerra de malvinas o falklands como la
llaman los británicos un conflicto que
en 1982 enfrentó argentina y reino unido
por la soberanía del archipiélago del
atlántico sur
este ese no está feo que se encuentra en
el centro de la ciudad de buenos aires-
recuerda a los
649 soldados argentinos caídos en los
combates
la guerra comenzó el 2 de abril de 1982
cuando tropas argentinas desembarcaron
en malvinas y terminó 74 días después
con el triunfo británico el conflicto
dejó profundas heridas en la sociedad
argentina
[Música]
el pasado 2 de abril en el día del
veterano y de los caídos en la guerra de
malvinas se llevó a cabo un acto para
conmemorar los 40 años del conflicto
durante la ceremonia se hizo entrega de
medallas a ex combatientes y familiares
de caídos quienes fueron el tema central
del discurso del presidente alberto
fernández
quiero que mis primeras palabras sean
para los soldados que dejaron su vida
para sus familias para todas las
veteranas y los veteranos
que sufrieron postergaciones
cuando hace pocos días decíamos con
fuerza y decisión
nunca más
también lo extendemos a nuestros héroes
y heroínas de marina para que nunca más
vuelvan a caer en el olvido y el
silencio de parte de ningún gobierno
en argentina la demanda por la soberanía
de malvinas es política de estado
también para el actual gobierno que
insiste en que reino unido cumpla con la
resolución del año 1965 de la asamblea
general de naciones unidas que llama a
proseguir sin demora las negociaciones
sobre la disputa de soberanía de las
islas
si antes de la guerra sobre todo unos
años antes había una relativa cercanía
entre ambos países a la hora de discutir
potenciales soluciones diplomáticas
después de la guerra eso creo en cero
hoy donde esta argentina sostiene
relaciones diplomáticas con el reino
unido no puede ser de otra manera este
si lo que queremos es justamente la
reapertura de las negociaciones lo que
si transmitimos a los funcionarios
británicos
[Música]
y exigencia al planteo de que el eje
central de nuestra relación bilateral
mientras no se resuelva la cuestión
malvinas va a ser la cuestión de la
soberanía argentina sobre sea parte del
territorio que se encuentra en sus pagos
por último el general los excombatientes
han tenido mucho reconocimiento en los
últimos últimos años muchos últimos años
pero hay un reclamo específico que tiene
que ver con justicia vinculado con los
abusos cometidos por sus superiores
durante la guerra hay algo que esté
cambiando respecto a esos reclamos
frente a la corte suprema- recientemente
en ese sentido que se está haciendo
estos casos están radicados ante la
justicia argentina hay un reclamo de
parte de los
ex combatientes que han sufrido
exámenes respecto de que la corte
nacional se expida el poder ejecutivo es
respetuoso de esas instancias judiciales
pero al mismo tiempo desde el poder
ejecutivo hemos confirmado como lo hizo
hoy el presidente que nuestra política
de malvinas también se enmarcan en las
políticas de memoria verdad y justicia
el que tienen que ver con el fuerte
compromiso de la argentina con el
respeto de los derechos humanos
[Música]
para algunos ex combatientes el vínculo
entre su historia y la defensa de los
derechos humanos es especialmente
estrecho sin desconocer el reclamo de
soberanía entienden que se trató de una
aventura militar llevada adelante por un
gobierno que llegó al poder a través de
un golpe de estado un golpe que tuvo
lugar el 24 de marzo de 1936
los miembros del centro de ex
combatientes islas malvinas de la plata
participaron como siempre hacen del acto
conmemorativo que tiene lugar en buenos
aires- todos los 24 de marzo si para el
país en general en la dictadura se
asocia con torturas y desapariciones en
el caso de los ex combatientes también
fue el régimen que lo llevó a combatir
en las islas mal preparados mal
equipados mal alimentados y en muchos
casos maltratados por sus superiores hoy
se conmemora un aniversario más de lo
que fue el golpe de estado a la
argentina los ex combatientes que nos
tocó la guerra de malvinas también
fuimos una continuidad de la dictadura y
creemos que esta manifestación tiene el
objetivo de seguir construyendo una
memoria colectiva que repudie para que
la argentina nunca más haya un golpe de
estado pero que también plante una
argentina que se proponga ser soberana
plena y en ese sentido estar acá es una
manifestación más de honrar la memoria
de nuestros compañeros que cayeron
los efectos de la guerra de malvinas en
argentina no cesaron el 14 de junio de
1982 con la rendición ante reino unido y
han sido especialmente profundos para
los ex combatientes aún años después del
conflicto se estima que son al menos 300
los ex soldados que se quitaron la vida
porque no soportaron la carga de lo que
vivieron sus nombres no están en este se
nota feo
gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de enlace conosur desde buenos aires
argentina los invito ahora a seguir con
la programación de france 24 en español